president biden is making a bipartisan
push to get his infrastructure deal
through congress
today he plans to meet with west
virginia senator shelly moore capito
she's leader of a group of republican
senators trying to hammer out a deal
now those republicans are trying to
limit the size of the package
and the president is appealing to
democrats to back him up
weisha zhang is at the white house with
more on the story rija good morning to
you the question is how close are they
to reaching a deal
good morning gail they're getting closer
but they're not there yet and now white
house officials they want at least a
clear path
forward on infrastructure by monday they
are
worried though that if a divided
congress cannot reach compromise on this
which is something that has widespread
public support
they won't be able to achieve anything
else on president biden's agenda
the latest republican offer offers one
trillion dollars about for projects to
fix roads
bridges and rails closer to president
biden's 1.7 trillion dollar proposal
but the white house is drawing attention
to several things that are
not funded in the gop package like
fixing veterans hospitals
removing dangerous lead pipes and
funding clean energy jobs
as the debate continues president biden
took a rare swipe at
two members of his own party
i hear all the folks on tv saying why
doesn't biden get this done
well because biden only has a majority
of effectively four votes in the house
and a tie in the senate with two
members of the senate who vote more with
my republican friends
president biden is referencing two
moderate democrats west virginia's joe
manchin and arizona's kirsten cinema
they are breaking with him and most
democrats by opposing a corporate tax
hike to pay for the infrastructure plan
the president is making moves in the
arctic the administration announced an
end to a trump-era oil drilling program
in alaska
that is considered sacred ground by an
indigenous group it's a wildlife refuge
anthony ouija thank you